[APPLAUSE]
PETER BARRON: Thanks very
much, everyone, for coming.
This is the first talk
at the new building.
It's great to have
such a full room.
And I'm told that larger
rooms will be available, too.
It's fantastic to have
Bastian Obermayer and Frederik
Obermaier, the so-called
brothers Obermayer--
although they're not brothers--
from "Suddeutsche Zeitung."
And they were
responsible for, really,
one of the biggest
scoops in modern times.
Certainly, the story involved
the biggest leak of data
that we've seen.
I think it was 11.5 million
documents and 2.6 terabytes
of information.
And a really
extraordinary story that's
told in "The Panama
Papers" book, first
of all, of how
they got the story,
and then how they
worked on the story,
and worked and
shared information
with a whole lot of
journalists around the world,
and then land really,
really big scoop.
So we're going to
talk about that today.
We'll throw it open to
questions pretty soon.
But Bastian, could
I kick off with you?
Where did it all begin?
BASTIAN OBERMAYER:
Well, to be honest,
it was a very bad day because
my kids were really sick.
And there was a lot of
whining and vomiting.
And I was a little tired.
And late at night,
I got this message.
Hi, this is John Doe.
Are you interested in data?
I'm willing to share.
I was interested.
But at the same time, I knew
I had to get back to my kids
and make tea and be nice.
But you have to be--
SPEAKER 1: We're going to use--
I'm going to pass you this
microphone to use--
BASTIAN OBERMAYER: OK.
SPEAKER 1: [INAUDIBLE]
BASTIAN OBERMAYER: And you also
have to be nice to a new source
because you have to have him--
give him or her the feeling
that you're really interested
in what he or she wants
to give you.
So it was a lot of running back
and forth and writing messages.
And in the end, we
got a first batch
of documents that looked
really interesting, not exactly
great or huge, but interesting.
And it became more and
more over the next days.
And so it started what is now
the biggest leak of all times.
And it started with only a batch
of documents on a bad night.
PETER BARRON: And when did
you know that you had a story?
Actually, could we
get one more mic here?
That would be great.
[LAUGHTER]
BASTIAN OBERMAYER:
Well, I think we
knew that we had
another good story when
we found the name of the
best friend of Vladimir Putin
in the data, the godfather
of his first daughter.
And he was in the midst of three
or four Panamanian companies.
And we saw hundreds of millions
of US dollars moved in there.
And we found an interview of
this guy, Sergei Roldugin,
in "The New York Times"
where-- he is an artist.
He plays the violin.
And he told "The New York
Times," I'm not a businessman.
I don't own millions.
So we were sitting
there and seeing
these millions of US dollars
running through the companies.
And we were like, well,
either he lied or he lied.
[LAUGHTER]
This is when we knew we
got a really good story.
And it got better
when we started
finding those heads of states.
In the end we had
like, 13, I guess,
that were directly
named in the papers.
And we had leads, meaning the
[? bankmen, ?] the brothers,
sisters, sons of
heads of states,
in the number of around 70.
PETER BARRON: Right.
So Frederik, normally--
you obviously
went-- Bastian took the
story, the initial story,
to your editors.
And they put both
of you on the story.
I think you'd worked on
investigations in the past.
But the normal course
of events with a scoop
is that you keep the scoop to
yourselves and then publish it
and whatever else happens.
In this case, you went down
a very different route.
Why did you decide to
share it internationally?
FREDERIK OBERMAIER: Well, that's
a question some colleagues
asked us at that time as well.
And they asked us in a
not-that-polite way, more
asking, are you crazy, guys?
But we have been part of formal
investigations of the ICIJ that
was stuff like Offshore
Leaks, Swiss Leaks,
and some investigations,
especially--
Google may know
there was Lux Leaks.
But at that time, we profited
from other media organizations
handing over data to the
ICIJ, sharing it and giving us
the possibility to work on this.
And for this time,
it was like, we
were convinced that it's
not only about taking
but also about giving.
And furthermore, in
this set of data,
we saw that there are so
many links to scandals
all around the world.
Because in the beginning,
it was like, when
we found a new name, a new
company, well, we googled it.
And sometimes we found
some hits involved
in a scandal in,
let's say, Mozambique.
And we were pretty
sure from the beginning
that we wouldn't be able to
report on all these stories
because the German
readership, for example,
would maybe not be that
interested in a story
about a scandal in Mozambique.
But it was maybe an important
story for Mozambique.
So we decided to share
it to give, then,
in this case-- or
in this example--
a journalist in
Mozambique the possibility
to write about this because the
data may be the missing puzzle
piece in a huge scandal.
PETER BARRON: And at
that stage, did you
have all the data in order to
keep coming in in extra bursts?
FREDERIK OBERMAIER: I'm sorry--
PETER BARRON: Did you have
all the data at that point?
Or were you-- you continued to
receive more as you went along?
FREDERIK OBERMAIER:
That was at a stage
when we had some hundred
gigabytes of data.
And we really thought,
well, wow, this
is a huge amount of data because
at that time, the biggest leak
we knew about was
Offshore Leaks.
And that was, I
think, 260 gigabytes.
And we had about 700 or
800 or something like that.
And we thought, wow, this
is such a big amount.
And the data keep
growing and growing.
So we had to buy new hard disks.
BASTIAN OBERMAYER:
Again and again.
FREDERIK OBERMAIER:
I learned that a hard drive
from two terabytes on you
need a special plug for
because it doesn't work well
with electricity.
And in the end, we turned
up with 2.6 terabytes.
And for me, it's still-- I'm
not that-- as you may know,
you're tech guys.
But I'm not.
I really had to look up
what 2.6 terabytes was.
And for me, it's like,
still-- well, it's big.
But I still have no
feeling for it-- how big.
PETER BARRON: And
so talk us through
the whole process of
keeping things safe
and using encryption
and secure channels.
Because the John Doe-- you've
never met John Doe, have you?
And you don't even
know who he is.
But you talked very, very
regularly to him, Bastian.
You were talking to him
every day for a long period.
BASTIAN OBERMAYER: Yeah, we had
a long-standing relationship.
We encrypted communications,
which we switched several times
to be more safe.
And we got the data in a
way that we obviously fully
can't tell now.
But it was very
complicated for me,
a guy who has no clue about
what I was doing there.
And we took all
kind of precautions
that we could learn about.
So we talked to many
people who helped us.
So we had an
air-gapped computer.
All of the information were
only stored on this one.
We had a special room
where our bosses weren't
allowed to get in, no security,
nobody except our team.
And we had a safe where we
stored all the hard drives
in it.
And we even had this nail
polish, this glitter nail
polish, to put on these
screws of the computer
so we could see if
anybody tried to get in.
PETER BARRON: Very James Bond.
BASTIAN OBERMAYER: Yeah,
it sounds ridiculous.
And my kids loved
the nail polish.
But we really tried hard
to do all to really protect
our source.
PETER BARRON: So did your family
know what you were working on
at the time?
BASTIAN OBERMAYER: Not exactly.
But if you say, my family,
I didn't tell my kids.
They are three and
five years old.
I could have told them--
no, thinking back,
they wouldn't have
understood it.
My wife knew some
because she had to know.
If you're investigating
Vladimir Putin and his buddies,
you better tell this because it
could change your life, I mean,
honestly.
And I think in your case,
it was the same, wasn't it?
FREDERIK OBERMAIER: Yeah,
I mean, I really tried
to keep it as a secret
as long as possible
because my girlfriend
was working
in the same business as me.
And we are-- journalists are
normally very talkative people.
But in the end, some
months before publication,
it was sure-- we
were both convinced
that we had to tell our partners
what we were doing because we
had to speak about security
measures, what even
our partners had to take
before publication, and even
after publication.
So, for example, in
my case, my family
was not in town when this
whole stuff broke loose
when we published it
because we, at that time,
we had no clue
what could happen.
In the end, everything
turned out fine.
Well, we had to take
precautions for the worst case.
PETER BARRON: And this
took many, many months
to come together.
So how-- what were
the precautions
that you took to make sure that
the story didn't get leaked
or that the journalists that
you shared the story with
would scoop you?
I mean, you had hundreds of
other journalists involved
around the world.
That's a scary process
over many months, isn't it?
FREDERIK OBERMAIER: Yes,
and the basic measure
for us was being
a pain in the ass
because we always told
them, every colleague
who was invited to this project,
well, this is very important
to keep it secret.
Don't tell your girlfriend.
Don't tell your colleagues.
Don't even tell your
boss what is in there.
And that was not that easy.
And the ICIJ was
even more repetitive.
They repeated it so many times.
But in the end, I think
all of our colleagues
realized what this
story's about,
and that it's not only about
some very technical issues--
tax havens, trusts,
limiteds, nominee directors--
but it's about the lives.
There could be lives in danger,
the life first and foremost
of the source,
John Doe, but then
also about-- of journalists
that worked with us on this
in the Middle East, Latin
America, and Africa, saying,
in countries where it's not
that easy to investigate stuff
like, well, the best friend
of Vladimir Putin or some drug
cartels.
I mean, because all
those guys, for them,
it's not that hard to harm
a person and a journalist.
PETER BARRON: Yeah.
And the whistle-blower
came to you guys.
It was obviously a
German publication.
But he was very keen that
the story would land right
around the world.
Isn't that right?
BASTIAN OBERMAYER: Right.
One of the first-- well, it
was not really a condition,
but it was a wish
that this person said,
maybe you don't only
publish in German,
because nobody reads German.
PETER BARRON: So why did
he come to "Suddeutsche"
in the first place?
BASTIAN OBERMAYER:
We don't really know.
We know now because we have
published his manifesto,
as "The Guardian" did, too, that
he or she approached other news
outlets, too, and didn't get
the real attention of the people
there.
And Jurgen Mossack, one of the
founders of Mossack Fonseca,
the Panamanian company,
he's from Furth in Bavaria,
in Germany.
So maybe this person
may have thought, well,
if nobody is
listening to me, I'm
going there where I see a local
connection between this company
and that country.
And once you're
looking in Germany
for somebody who was involved in
leaks or in tax haven stories,
you would maybe go to
"Suddeutsche Zeitung"
because, as he said, we get
Offshore Leaks and Luxembourg
Leaks and Swiss Leaks.
So this-- if you're
looking in Germany,
it's kind of rational
to talk to us.
But we don't know why he
chose to go to our country.
PETER BARRON: So tell us a
bit more about Mr. Mossack,
because he's a pretty
secretive figure.
What was his background?
And what's he doing now?
FREDERIK OBERMAIER:
Well, his background
was pretty strange
for us as Germans
because we looked at how
this German ended up there
in Panama.
Panama is very far from Germany.
And we saw that his father, who
was a member of the Waffen-SS--
so he was a Nazi.
And we ducked into the
archives and found out
that his father ended up
working for this-- I mean,
he emigrated after the war.
And he ended up in Panama
working there, it seems like,
being an informant for the CIA.
And, well, his sons--
there's not only one,
but there are
two-- they studied.
And Jurgen Mossack became a
pretty famous person in Panama.
I mean, I went there-- and
if you speak to the people
there in the financial
district, they all
speak about El Aleman, "the
German," because he's famous,
because he has very
influential friends.
His partner, his partner
in business, Ramon Fonseca,
was an adviser to the president.
He was a member of the
ruling party in Panama.
So they are people you
don't mess with in Panama.
But at the same
time, in Germany,
they've been pretty unknown.
I think if you would have
asked somebody in Germany one
year ago, "who is Jurgen
Mossack?" it would be like,
"Jurgen who?"
But now, I think some
people may know his name.
PETER BARRON: So
Mossack Fonseca,
what was their business model?
What was their approach to
selling offshore companies?
FREDERIK OBERMAIER:
Well, officially, they
are a law firm.
But their business is they are
setting up offshore companies
all around the world in
whatever tax haven you name.
And then they're
selling secrecy.
So you can talk to them--
well, I want it secret,
I want it very secret, or
very, very, very secret.
And then they put in
nominee directors,
people that can pretend to
be the real owners if they
are asked.
So it's like, they are helping
you to hide your money.
And it depends on how much money
you do have to hide your money
and how much you want
to put into this.
They are offering very,
very complex structures.
PETER BARRON: OK, well,
let's talk about some
of their famous clients.
You mentioned Mr.
Putin's best friend,
also David Cameron's father,
senior executives at Siemens.
How did you discover
who these people were
and where your stories lay?
FREDERIK OBERMAIER:
Well, In the beginning,
it was really like
trial and error.
Because when we received the
data, we processed it like,
OCRing it and making
it searchable.
And then it was like,
well, I put in a name.
Bastian is a soccer fan.
And he's a fan of a
soccer team in Germany
that is not that famous.
It's from Munich, but it's
not the big one in Munich.
So he always googled the
players and former presidents
and presidents of
FT Bayern Munich.
And we, of course, looked for
Angela Merkel, Helmut Kohl,
and the politicians.
But then we soon realized
that we have to do it
in a more structured way.
We put up lists like--
the simplest one was well,
all members of parliament
since the founding
of the German-- of
Germany, so the founding
of the Federal Republic.
And with this, we
did it on-- we'd then
look for all the major scandals
in the history of Germany
after World War II and looked
for the people involved,
the companies involved,
and we had many, many hits.
And so it was a
mixture of making
fun searches and fun was like,
well, we are here at Google.
So who are the
bosses from Google?
Then let's search for them.
And--
PETER BARRON: Zero.
BASTIAN OBERMAYER: We
haven't found it yet, OK.
[LAUGHTER]
FREDERIK OBERMAIER: --and doing
the structured way as well.
PETER BARRON: OK, then
let's talk about the impact.
So when the story-- you
kept everything safe
and then launched the
story internationally
on the same day.
Tell us a little bit
about what happened next.
BASTIAN OBERMAYER:
Well, we have to start
with what happened before
this because, I think,
13 minutes before we
broke it, Edward Snowden
had it on Twitter,
which we, until now,
don't know how he did it.
But he learned his job, so
he knew what he was doing,
I think.
And so after this,
it was like a tsunami
that broke because it
was so many reactions
from the whole world.
And I mean, you're
used to write something
if you did Offshore Leaks
and Lux Leaks before,
but we were not used to
having mass demonstrations
in several countries
because of your story.
And Vladimir Putin
accused us of being
owned by Goldman Sachs,
which is just a blatant lie.
And you know, the Prime
Minister stepped back
from Iceland, and
all this stuff.
And we were for three
weeks, we were in a tunnel
and didn't have the
time to read anything
or to watch the
films that were made.
It was really a
completely crazy time.
And if you see Barack Obama
in the White House talking
about that after
Panama Papers, he
has to [INAUDIBLE] his nation.
It's all like, did
he really say this?
And now, it gets
a little calmer.
So we can look back
at this, and we can
start [INAUDIBLE] pieces done.
Our colleagues had
written back by then.
So it was really
very interesting
what happened there.
PETER BARRON: And have you
heard from your source?
Have you heard from
the whistle-blower
since the story broke?
BASTIAN OBERMAYER: Well, as we
have published the manifesto,
we can say that there
has been a contact.
And we know that this person is
quite happy about what happened
and how it played out.
But we do not comment if there's
still any kind of contact.
PETER BARRON: OK, right.
And Mossack Fonseca,
what of them?
They were rid by the police
from a number of countries
shortly after the
revelations were made.
Have you heard from them?
Is there-- are they
continuing to do business?
BASTIAN OBERMAYER:
They're trying.
They had to close
down six offices
in six tax havens and the
private banking department.
But we don't know
what will happen
after the raids in
Venezuela and El Salvador
and in the main
quarters in Panama.
The raid, I think,
took 28 hours.
But we would not
be very surprised
if their friends in government
will tell us in a month
that they have
really checked all,
and it's all perfectly legal
and fine and no harm being done
FREDERIK OBERMAIER: Well,
and closing down the offices
has-- as far as Mossack
Fonseca claims-- nothing
to do with the Panama Papers.
[LAUGHTER]
BASTIAN OBERMAYER: Sure.
PETER BARRON: Pure coincidence.
PETER BARRON: Tough times.
OK, questions from
the audience--
who would like to ask
the gentlemen a question?
Over here.
SPEAKER 1: Please wait
for the microphone
on this-- [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: So
firstly, I would like
to say that I think this is a
great thing that this leaked
and that you wrote about this.
After these papers were leaked
out, I think a lot of people,
including me, were
really excited
that things might
change in this respect
and that these people
would have to be taxed.
But it seems that
since the publication,
nothing has happened
on the global scale.
So it seems that-- I'm
assuming Mossack Fonseca is
going bankrupt slowly.
But overall, there's no
changes in taxes or anything.
Or maybe I am wrong,
and they are happening?
So what's your view on this?
Are you happy with
the things that
happened since your publication,
or were you expecting more?
FREDERIK OBERMAIER:
Well, I mean, we
are journalists, not activists.
So for us it was like,
well, we published it.
And now let's see what is
happening and report about it.
But I'm not that pessimistic
because we have already
seen some changes.
We have seen Panama
agreeing to be
part of the automatic
exchange of information.
That's something they
denied in the past years.
We have the US
leaders discussing it.
We have an Inquiry Commission
from the European Parliament
now.
There are investigations
in dozens of countries.
So I think that's some
movement going on.
And we do hear from
the offshore business
that they are not
feeling really good.
Because it was-- also, we
reported only on one law firm.
And there are many companies
offering the same services
all around the world.
We do see that they are feeling
a little bit nervous because I
think now they realized after
all these leaks-- I mean,
Offshore Leaks, Swiss
Leaks, now this one--
they realize that they
cannot feel safe anymore.
So if your business
is selling secrecy,
and you do see that
there have been
several leaks in
this field, well, you
should think about if it's still
possible to keep your stuff
secret.
And I think we have to
look closely now what
is going to happen.
And it's not only to us as
journalists, it's to all of you
to stick to this
topic, where I must
admit that may be,
at first glance,
not that sexy because
speaking about tax havens
seems technical at
the first glance.
But you always have
to be aware that's
an issue that regards all of
us because there are billions
of dollars or pounds missing for
all of us if taxes are evaded.
And at the same time,
it's not only about taxes.
Its about criminals
hiding their wrongdoings
using offshore companies.
It's people like the cousin
of Bashar al-Assad evading
sanctions by using
those companies.
So this is something
that is very
important for every one of us.
PETER BARRON: Next question.
AUDIENCE: Well,
thank you very much.
I wanted to ask about--
because, I guess,
that the first impression-- or,
I don't know, for many of us--
was that this
whistle-blower was kind
of a hero that revealed this.
And now, because of him, we
can know about the whole issue.
Did you consider the
possibility that the guy maybe
didn't have the good intentions,
like, he was whistle-blowing
the bad guys, but there were
even worse guys behind him
or something like that?
I mean, how do you consider
whether this is a good thing
to do or not, if
you care about it?
BASTIAN OBERMAYER:
Well, first of all,
we look at the documents.
And if you see a
public interest there,
and we think they're
not falsified,
then we know we have to do the
story because it's important.
And the motivation
is secondplace.
And still, I mean, we
talked more than a year
with this person.
And we have the
impression-- and that's
what we've been told-- that this
person feels a moral obligation
to do so because he or she is
in the-- is capable to do it,
to give this data away.
And we talked a
lot now to people
who have very good insights
in secret services.
And they all say, nobody would
give away a weapon like this
because you don't
know what's in there.
It's 11.5 million documents.
No secret service would
know what's all in there.
And we got it in real time.
So we got a bunch of stuff-- 100
gigabytes-- and we found emails
from the day before.
So it was not really
possible to go through it
and clear it for documents you
don't want us to have, maybe.
So I don't think that
there is some bad intention
from the secret service.
We have been accused that
we are working for the CIA.
We've been accused we've
been working for the KGB.
There have been some accusations
the Mossad, because Mossack
and Mossad, it's so close.
[LAUGHTER]
And so we cannot be sure,
of course, because we--
if it's the secret service,
you never know who's behind.
I don't really know if the
secret service is here is
secretly paying this guy here.
I don't know.
[LAUGHTER]
He says no, but I don't
really know because it's
the secret service.
PETER BARRON: But did you
cooperate with the authorities
in any way?
If crimes were
committed, is there
any responsibility to hand over
documents to the authorities?
BASTIAN OBERMAYER: No,
no, we don't do this.
They have their chances
and their possibilities.
They can do raids any time.
They can do better laws.
They haven't done their
homework for years.
And you know, if they
want to go after offshore,
well, they can do it.
This is not a problem.
They have special police.
They have all kinds of
weapons that we don't have.
And you know, if
the whistle-blower
wants to have it done, he can
give the data to authorities.
But this is not our job.
FREDERIK OBERMAIER: But, I
mean, what we are actually doing
is that the stories we
published on our website--
that we are trying to put
as much original documents
on our web page so the
authorities can, of course, use
them to start their
investigations.
AUDIENCE: So this is Google.
And one of our missions
is to kind of look at data
and analyze and understand it.
And the forefront
of that right now
is artificial intelligence
on computers, where computers
can go and understand the
structures of documents
and find meanings
and things like that.
And have you guys
considered or approached
anyone that has machine--
artificial intelligence
expertise that
could do automated
analysis of the Panama Papers?
FREDERIK OBERMAIER: I'm glad
that you didn't ask, well,
can Google have it over there?
[LAUGHTER]
Yes, actually, we had
somebody approaching us
on that in a rather
abstract way when we already
worked on the Panama Papers.
But at that stage, we couldn't
tell the person, well,
we have something on there,
let's go in and try it.
But I had heard a
lengthy discussion
with this expert--
it was a German one--
in an abstract way,
already knowing,
well, we would have something.
And I didn't get the
impression that it's already--
I'm not the tech guy-- this
is a field that is already
so far developed that it would
be very, very useful to analyze
the Panama Papers.
AUDIENCE: We have some
machine translation
that you can take things and
translate it into other spaces
and things like that.
FREDERIK OBERMAIER:
That's something
that some colleagues
of ours already
used, for example, to
analyze the documents, some--
it's no secret.
It's our Swiss colleagues who
have a very great tool on that.
PETER BARRON: But if
you look at WikiLeaks,
they took the decision to
put everything out there,
and people could make
of it what they would.
Did you consider that approach?
I mean, you cherry-picked
the stories.
You didn't put all of
it out there, did you?
FREDERIK OBERMAIER:
No, I mean, of course,
we thought about that as well.
But for me personally,
it would feel--
and it is, in my opinion--
it wouldn't be responsible
regarding the source because
I personally could not
be 100% percent sure that
in this bunch of documents
that there are no links to
the source named John Doe.
And if somebody is
looking for John Doe,
and I'm sure that there are some
guys out there who really would
like to meet this person and
not meeting for a drink, that,
in my opinion, that
wouldn't be responsible.
And furthermore,
according to German law,
this would not be possible
because in Germany, we have
a rather strict law of privacy.
So putting all these documents
in an unredacted way out there
would get us in court nearly
every day for the future years.
And redacting this bunch
of documents, I mean,
that's too much.
So as much as I would really
like to do something like that,
I tend to-- I want to
investigate stories
and not redacting documents
for the next years.
BASTIAN OBERMAYER: Millions.
FREDERIK OBERMAIER: Millions.
PETER BARRON: OK, next question.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank
you for the talk.
And thank you for the
excellent journalistic work.
I'm wondering if you are at
all worried a phenomenon that
seems to happen
where since the leak,
there has been an increasing
support for fringe
and extremist political
movements, sometimes
financed by exactly the
people involved in the leak,
somewhat paradoxically.
And if you're worried
about this, what can
the press do against it?
BASTIAN OBERMAYER: Well, I
haven't linked Boris Johnson
to the Panama Papers--
[LAUGHTER]
--yet, but if you say so.
No, I haven't seen a
relationship between this yet.
We have to think about it.
But what do you
mean, for example?
AUDIENCE: It seems
that, since the leaks,
there has been-- support
in most institutions
has eroded because
people trust it less.
And they think that
all the governments
have people in them who are
appearing in the papers.
And that drives people to
vote for extremist parties
or right-wing parties,
sometimes financed by people
who appear in the leaks.
What happened in
UK-- there seems
to-- that Arron Banks
appears in that list.
And he's a backer of UKIP.
And UKIP is using
the Panama Papers
to get their support,
somewhat paradoxically.
BASTIAN OBERMAYER:
Well, I don't think
that we started the erosion
in trust of politicians.
Maybe it's one more small
piece that many people
think, you know, the elites, the
1% is having a separate life.
And the powerful and the
rich, they can really
decide if, when, and
how much taxes they
want to pay, for example.
And we cannot change it.
This is what we see
in the Panama Papers.
And this is what you see in
many places, if you look there.
And so we need the
big parties to fight
against this phenomenon
and not saying,
the others are using this now.
They should be
using it themselves
and should be
illegal, for a change.
That's my opinion, at least.
PETER BARRON: Next question.
Over here.
AUDIENCE: So obviously, the kind
of investigative journalism you
guys did is hugely-- it's
a huge public benefit.
But I would be curious to
know if you see anything
you can share about whether it
actually kind of financially
works for newspapers, which
I think is often a concern.
Obviously you spent
months working on this.
You probably had to hire lawyers
and technical consultants.
It was a very expensive thing.
Does this result in-- do you
see a higher circulation?
Does it pay for itself?
Or is basically a loss leader
for a newspaper to do this?
FREDERIK OBERMAIER:
Well, what we
did see was actually
a higher circulation.
We did have by far more
access to our web page.
It's no secret that our servers
broke down in the first 24
hours because there were
so-- been so many people
reading the articles of
this newspaper in Germany.
And it was the first time in
the history of a newspaper,
for example, that
the English articles
had more access and more clicks
than the German articles.
But regarding facts and
figures in regards to money,
we don't have any figures
if it really pays off.
And I really hope
that our bosses do not
start this calculation.
Well, this Bastian
worked more than a year.
He did cost that, and
then the computers.
Then we, well, we
see some more clicks.
Because we really believe that
investigative journalism is not
something you should value
with, well, more clicks and more
circulation.
It's about the duty we
have to do to society.
And we want to uncover
wrongdoings and stuff that
should be out there.
And if we only value journalism
in regards to clicks and stuff
like that, in the
end, we will only
be publishing pictures
and videos of cats.
And that's not
what I want to do.
PETER BARRON: Is
there something in
the collaborative international
model of journalism
that signals how the
future of journalism
might work in a more
sustainable way?
BASTIAN OBERMAYER: Well, I
think that what we all saw,
and [INAUDIBLE] especially,
is that it really
boosted our reputation.
And so the name was not
really out there before.
And if our colleagues,
our co-subordinates,
were asking for interviews,
they mainly heard, where are you
from? "Suddeutsche
Zeitung," this
is the country next to Albania
that has free press, too?
Cool.
And so now they can say,
you know the newspaper
that made the Panama Papers?
And it makes--
[SNAPS]
And we see this on
many of our colleagues
that Swiss leaks
and Panama Papers
have really helped them to
further develop their ideas
and what they were doing.
But it's not a fear where
you make high profits
from many things.
It's more something that you
can help build a good name
for your newspaper or for your
media, whatever you work for.
PETER BARRON: Next question.
AUDIENCE: So you
mentioned that Panama
has agreed to exchange
information for the first time
after many times asking.
What do you think this means
for tax havens everywhere?
Do you think this is going
to send a signal that this
is probably
information that they
should have publicly available?
Or do you think
there won't be much
of a difference in the future?
BASTIAN OBERMAYER: Well, it
all depends on our politicians.
And while being the UK, there
are the British Virgin Islands.
And there's Guernsey and Jersey.
So there's a lot of work to do.
And I think the pressure
has never been this high.
It's a little sad that
Mr. Cameron left office
because he was, especially
in a [? branchement, ?]
as his father was included.
But I think that
we will see change.
But we cannot easily
judge know how much.
And I think that the very
easy way of using offshore
with all of the banks
or the big German banks
used in the last year that
you go there to, for example,
Deutsche Bank in
Switzerland, and you say,
I have this 500,000 euros,
and I really hate taxes.
And they would say,
yeah, I've got this idea.
You just buy a
Panamanian company,
you get a bank account in
Switzerland, and that's it.
And this doesn't work
anymore because the banks are
really afraid of bad publicity.
And nobody knows who's next
in terms of being leaked.
So what is happening now-- if
you go there with your 500,000
euros and say, I hate
taxes, they look at you
and say, well,
that's your problem.
But we cannot help you.
But if you go there, and
you say, I have 50 million,
and I don't like
taxes, they say,
well, we'd find a solution.
And you'll have 15
lawyers setting up
a very complex
structure involving
production work in Ireland
and I don't know what.
And in the end, the
government needs 50 lawyers
to really decide,
is it legal or not?
It's on the edge.
This is-- you will never
stop this, I think.
AUDIENCE: Have you
exhausted the 2.6 terabytes,
or is there much more to
investigate within the data
set?
FREDERIK OBERMAIER: Yes,
we didn't have it exhausted
because it's so many documents.
And I'm sure that there
are thousands of documents
still in there where no
journalist of this 400 even
clicked on once.
But I hope that we have at least
the biggest stories already
found.
But there are so many
stories and leads
we are still following.
And there are
fields that have not
been covered that much as they
should have been in the past.
So that's the reason why we
added-- and the ICIJ added
more reporters on it from
countries, for example,
recently from Mongolia
or from Turkey.
So our Turkish colleagues
published their first Panama
Papers story today.
And I'm pretty optimistic
that there are still
some great stories
coming out of the data.
And we still have to say
that there is so much data
coming from the 70s or end of
the 70s, 80s, and early 90s,
what is basically facsimiles
or handwritten documents.
And although we believe we
have a pretty good OCR systems,
I'm pretty sure
that there are so
many names in
there that have not
been OCRd in a very good way.
So there could be the pope
and his brother in there.
And we wouldn't
have found him now.
And, I mean, I hope
that in the end,
there are so many journalists
working on it that we will find
the real big stories in there.
But that may take some time.
PETER BARRON: And are you still
both working on this full time?
Is this your job at the moment?
FREDERIK OBERMAIER: When we are
not speaking to you, then yes.
Yes, we don't do any other
stories apart from it.
PETER BARRON: And
that, presumably,
is going to carry on for some
time to come, is that right?
FREDERIK OBERMAIER: Well, I
hope that our boss will let us--
and don't remind him that there
may be other stories out there
as well.
PETER BARRON: Next question.
AUDIENCE: You said you
had to tell your family
about the story before, like a
month before, because you were
worried about their security.
Since the story broke,
have you ever felt
you were in actual danger,
or was it all good?
BASTIAN OBERMAYER:
Well, we felt in danger
while we did all the research
because this is the phase where
you're most vulnerable,
where nobody knows out
in the world what are you
doing, and when people think
they might be able to stop you.
After we published, nothing
happened in Germany.
So we didn't have any
threats, no calls, no emails,
no letters, aside from
legal letters from lawyers
who said they want to sue us.
[LAUGHTER]
But nothing really happened.
And we had worldwide-- our
Russian colleagues had to leave
the country for a time.
And a colleague in
Venezuela has been fired.
Others have been intimidated.
But nobody was harmed until now.
So this is really good.
And we have-- the biggest
protection of all of us
is that we are so many.
Because we can say the
sentence that now, I think,
460 colleagues have
access to the data.
So if you want to
stop one of them,
you'll have 459 very,
very angry colleagues
doing exactly this story.
So it's not possible
to stop it anymore.
It's like a life assurance, at
least we hope so for many of us
because it's so decentral
and so globalized.
PETER BARRON: And are
you being sued by anyone?
Are there any active
cases against you?
BASTIAN OBERMAYER: Yeah,
there's one guy in Germany
who is crazy.
And he's suing against the
newspaper and the book,
the book again, and a
broadcasting station.
It's a private
investigator, and he thinks
that we put his life in danger.
And we don't think so.
And this is before court now.
But it's-- he's fighting
very small sentences,
like which car he drove back
then, back like, 30 years--
it's not really important.
It's not a big problem for us.
And we really had the big fear
that some broad billionaire
would sue us in
London or New York.
So we would really need to pay
a lot of money to big lawyers,
to expensive lawyers.
And if a billionaire's
in the mood,
he can sue us in
London and in New York.
And this would have
been really a problem,
especially if we would had
make a lot of mistakes.
Our biggest fear was to make
any real mistake that we
have to go to court for.
But we haven't found one yet.
And if we don't [INAUDIBLE].
PETER BARRON: Fine.
So given that you're
not being sued,
can you say a little bit
more about Mr. Putin?
Because that case-- that was an
extraordinary case, wasn't it?
So we have a cello player who
is moving hundreds of millions
of dollars around the world.
And he happens to be the
godfather of Putin's child.
Tell us a little
bit more about that.
FREDERIK OBERMAIER: Well,
first and foremost, it
was interesting to
see that not even
Putin questioned the
authenticity of the documents.
He said he thinks
they're authentic.
He doesn't like
our interpretation
And then he came up with the
story of "Suddeutsche Zeitung"
being owned by Goldman Sachs,
what was actually wrong.
And his spokesperson had to
admit that mistake, which
was a great page one for
us because the Kremlin
doesn't say sorry
to "Suddeutsche
Zeitung" every day.
And it was funny to be--
to see that the wife
of the spokesperson was in
the Panama Papers as well.
So I mean, still,
apart from fun,
it is still an
extraordinary story,
in my opinion, because we do
see that it's still developing.
We published the story.
And afterwards, we
find more links.
We found links, for
example, to the biggest tax
fraud in Russian history in it.
And we didn't see it at once.
And there are still colleagues
of ours working on this case.
And the explanations
of the Kremlin,
of this musician,
Sergei Roldugin,
they are not the best ones.
And, I mean, we do
see him in the center
of a network of companies that
funneled around $2 billion
in not that many years.
And the explanation was
that, well, this guy's
buying some instruments.
And with that
amount of money, you
can really buy an
army of instruments.
So I think that's not that
good of an excuse for it.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Yes, thanks for
the presentation.
And thanks for the amazing
work that you've done there.
Just regarding the procedure of
the release of the documents,
do you have a feeling
that John Doe learned
from the lessons of
previous releases,
like thinking of Julian
Assange and Ed Snowden?
Surely he must
think, I don't want
to end up in somewhere
holed-up, in an embassy
in a foreign country
or elsewhere.
Did he feel-- or did he
insist on certain protocols
to keep him safe?
FREDERIK OBERMAIER: The answer
is, I had the impression, yes.
I mean, we do see Chelsea
Manning being imprisoned.
We saw Snowden being
trapped in Moscow.
And I think-- at least
I had the impression--
that John Doe learned the
lesson from them by not
telling anybody who he is.
I mean it was not only keeping
it secret from the public,
but also keeping
it secret from us.
Because you can put a
pistol on our heads,
and we won't be able
to say the identity
or the name of the John Doe
because we don't know it.
And I think in
these times, I think
this was the best way of
staying alive and staying free.
And I think, unfortunately,
it is the only recommendation
I can give a whistle-blower
in these times
because we do see so many
whistle-blowers being
in trouble.
We saw just recently this week,
the Lux Leaks whistle-blower
facing court in Luxembourg.
And I think
whistle-blowers should not
be the ones facing court.
They should be the ones
we all should applaud to.
And I hope we will
all-- politicians
will learn the
lessons and realize
that there is a
need for a better
protection of
whistle-blowers because it's
all of us benefiting
from whistle-blowers that
run-- that risk their lives
by handing over documents
to journalists or
to authorities.
And that's the reason
why we should really
fight for a better protection
of whistle-blowers.
PETER BARRON: Last
couple of questions.
Sir?
360.
AUDIENCE: So the
stories that really
make the headlines are,
of course, the ones where
a major public figure, such as
a head of state, is involved.
But for every major
public figure,
there must be lots of
not well-known names
in those papers.
To what extent have
the stories that
have come out just--
do they just represent
the tip of the iceberg?
Or is it really mostly
sort of major figures
who are involved in
this tax evasion?
BASTIAN OBERMAYER: No, it's
the upper tip of the iceberg
because you have
the many persons who
used Mossack Fonseca
and are not famous,
so we are not
allowed to name them.
And then you have the many other
companies like Mossack Fonseca
having the same kind of client.
So it's really depressing
if you think about it.
But still, we
would, in some way,
like the authorities to have the
data because then everybody can
be looked after.
But we don't know
what will happen.
Maybe John Doe wants
the same thing,
and maybe he gives it away.
And if not, we just
have to look for stories
with certain public interests
so we can publish it.
PETER BARRON: Final question.
Right here.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
From reading the papers,
do you have the impression
that everybody working
at Mossack Fonseca
was aware of what
was going on there?
Or only a few people
in the company
were actually aware of all
the bad stuff happening there?
BASTIAN OBERMAYER: Well, I
think that most people knew
because it's, I mean,
what do you think
the anonymous companies in
Panama are used for if not
for people who want to hide
their traces in some way?
And we see a lot
of stuff where they
were talking about the
cousin of Bashar al-Assad.
And they were like,
hey, he's sanctioned--
shouldn't this be a red
flag for everybody here?
Yes, it should have been.
But they just
ignored this red flag
and kept him as a customer.
And we see many examples
where they just didn't care.
And they did so because they
were really sure that nobody
could get them because
it's all so secret
and nobody can look into it.
So there weren't
in each case really
another way around--
they didn't want
to know a lot in many cases.
They weren't really interested.
They were just giving
away the company
with its name, made
a bank account,
and didn't ask many questions.
But we see many
examples where they
saw what the money was used for,
like in a big famous bribery
scandal.
And they completely knew
where the money came from.
And they just didn't care.
And we have many
examples of this.
And I think the whole fear--
the many people working
in the offshore
companies, they know
what it is used for because
it's common knowledge.
So it will not come as a
surprise for the people
working there that they
are used for tax evasion.
That's what it is for.
That's what it was made for.
So I don't think
that we have to be
very careful about the
people working there.
Although the smaller
guys, of course,
they are not as guilty
as the big guys.
PETER BARRON:
Thank you very much
indeed, gentlemen,
Bastian and Frederik.
And congratulations.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]